if secrets was just released in
paperback it has a new after word
dealing with issues in the intelligence
community in the weeks leading up to
September 11th mr. Bamford spoke
recently about his book and the current
debate over intelligence gathering and
anti-terrorism efforts in the u.s. this
event at the independent Institute in
Oakland California is an hour in 20
minutes
largely because of the work of James
Bamford the public knows that the ultra
secret National Security Agency the
largest and most powerful of all
espionage organizations the United
States operates a global systems by
satellites but few know of its roles in
the Cold War the hunt for bin Laden and
echelon the world wide net NSA spying
system that monitors millions of
innocent people no outsider knows more
about the NSA than James Bamford who has
been researching the issue for many
years in fact his previous book puzzle
palace was published before most members
of Congress even knew about the NSA mr.
Bamford is the author of body of secrets
and puzzle palace as I mentioned he's
been a Washington investigative reporter
for ABC's World News Tonight
he's written cover stories the New York
Times Magazine the Washington Post
magazine in the LA Times Magazine
he's currently distinguished visiting
faculty at the Goldman School of Public
Policy at the University of California
Berkeley I'm very pleased to introduced
James Bamford
thank you David I appreciate it in it's
a real honor to speak before you today
and follow such luminaries as gore Vidal
and so forth so it's a real honor to be
here today I appreciate it
David mentioned that even some members
of Congress didn't know about NSA when
might when the puzzle palace came out in
1982 I had to do a book tour and I had
to go on a one of the shows as a public
broadcasting program the I can't
remember the name of it right now but it
was based in Dennis Dennis for Lee show
I think he still has his show on TV and
I was gonna go there to talk about the
NSA and one of the other people that was
gonna be on the show was gonna be
Senator Bill Bradley from New Jersey so
we got in the same car rode over to the
studio he was going to talk about the
economy and I was gonna talk about NSA
so in the car he said what's your book
about and I said it's about NSA the
National Security Agency and he said
what's that so I proceeded for the rest
of the car ride explain what the largest
intelligence agency was to the senator
when we got on the on the show the first
question the host asked was how secret
is NSA I just couldn't resist it and I
said even senator Bradley said he never
heard of it say he took a separate car
back to the hotel
the next day is a called me up and said
that was really below the belt and I
said I'm just telling the truth he's one
of a hundred people that really should
know how the government works and and I
said if I wanted to hit him below the
belt I would have said he probably
confused it with the NBA which I didn't
but not only Congress but when the book
came out I got picked by Book of the
Month Club as a selection so like every
author you get the New York Times Book
Review look at your little jacket on the
back with all the other well the famous
author is Stephen King and all that and
I just couldn't believe it when I saw
mine cuz I said the puzzle palace a
report on NASA America's most secret
agency and the ad agency he thought I
had made a mistake on my own book so
they voluntarily changed NSA to to NASA
I mean the only advantage was I probably
sold copies to a few astronauts that
might not have ordinarily bought it and
even in book stores I would go in there
and they would they would have a I go to
where that book was supposed to be it
won't be there and I go up to the desk
and ask about it and they a lot of times
would say yes we have five copies it's
back in the puzzle section so this time
I changed it to it's a body of secrets
but I think was Barnes & Noble one of
those changed yeah I'm putting a
discount sticker on it and they covered
up the of so it says body secrets
and so people are thinking I'm writing
about the g-spot or something like that
and they say is an extremely secret
agency when I wrote the puzzle palace it
was the very first book ever written
about NSA and I'd never thought I'd have
to write a second one but after I wrote
puzzle palace nobody came along and
followed in my footsteps so I ended up
writing body of secrets about 20 years
later and which is only the second book
written on NSA so I sort of have a
monopoly on that topic at this point the
government was not very happy that I
wrote the puzzle palace or was not very
happy that I was writing the puzzle
palace and they twice threatened me with
prosecution even though I never worked
for NSA I never signed any Clarence
forms with NSA or anything else they
just didn't like anybody writing on NSA
maybe old old saying at NSA is that the
NSA stands for no such agency and
internally it so the joke is it stands
for never say anything and then when the
puzzle palace came out they said that
joke now as it stands for not secret
anymore but it was still very secret I
didn't barely scratch the surface so
they they also were unhappy that I got
documents out of a particular library
down at the George C Marshall research
library down in Lexington Virginia it's
on the campus of the Virginia Military
Institute so they went down to the
library after the book came out and they
actually raided the library and they
began pulling off things from the shelf
and order them ordering the archivist to
lock them in vaults and so forth this is
after the books already come out I mean
I didn't really understand the logic of
that I mean if you do it before the you
know the horse is out of the barn I
could see but as a result of that the
the government as a result of
government's actions the library as well
as the American Civil Liberties Union
the American Library Association the
American Historical Association they all
sued NSA over that
you shouldn't be able to go into a
private library and pull out
non-classified private documents these
were not government documents these were
private letters by one of the
individuals that formerly worked for NSA
the one of the founders of NSA way my
Friedman so the history of writing on
NSA is not a history of ease you have to
fight the government every way another
problem with trying to write on it is
the Freedom of Information Act which is
usually a very important tool but NSA is
the only agency that's excluded from the
Freedom of Information Act little thing
called public law 86 36 subsection 6
which I know by heart says Congress
shall make no law requiring NSA to
divulge any information about its
organization function structure salary
personnel or any other information so I
had to find sort of loopholes in these
in these that public ID 636 and I was
successful in fighting the government
over over the a number of documents I
requested I ended up getting more than
5,000 pages worth so the history is just
a lot of hard work and trying to get
anything out of this agency when I wrote
this new book I approached the agency
and again I got the same the same
response you know we're not gonna help
you
we're not gonna give you any interviews
or any allowing the agency or blah blah
blah but then a new director came along
and saw the logic and allowing at least
uh you know a book to be written about
it I had written the puzzle palace and
the world did not come to an end after
that as a matter of fact the government
ended up using the book as a textbook in
a defense intelligence college so and it
was really only the NSA that was that
was going crazy the State Department
actually invited me over to give an
address to the senior officials at the
State Department a thing called the
Secretary of State's open forum and they
have me for lunch in the Secretary's
dining room afterwards at the same time
the NSA
coming after me so with this book though
it was different the new director came
along saw the value of having at least a
another book that last one was 20 years
ago when the puzzle files came out and
one of the key reasons was Hollywood was
creating this image of NSA as an agency
full of assassins an enemy of the state
for example the Director of Operations
or the deputy director I think it was
assassinated a congressman because of
Billy didn't like so so NSA thought that
you know if there was a impressionable
teenagers or whatever see this movie and
they are interested in NSA it might be
useful to have a book that's least
accurate in the in the library in the
bookstores so they did agree to help me
and they let me in the door and gave me
tours through the agency interviews with
senior officials and they didn't help me
with the documents but once again I
found new polls so I got another about a
couple thousand pages worth of documents
at the same time the the agency when the
book came out instead of threatening me
with prosecution this time they had a
book signing for me which was very
strange they I think they were
originally they wanted access to the
book they wanted to have access to the
Pope before it was published as I could
see what you know what was in it and
what was good or not and I just said you
know having done this for 25 years I'm
not gonna start now giving you no
censorship rights to government agencies
so eventually they backed off and they
they gave me the access anyway and I
never ended up giving them any advance
notice any advance copy of the book they
saw the book when everybody else got it
in the bookstore so I said the books
untainted by NSA's own censorship no
nevertheless the agency
you know they think they they realize
the value of it and I think they've
appreciated the book I think it's a I
think it came as a shock to everybody
that they actually had a book signing it
actually went on for four hours up there
and and originally when the puzzle
palace came out they they had basically
told all the employees they couldn't buy
it and couldn't discuss it so it's very
interesting during the book signing and
seeing all these employees walk up with
copies of their puzzle palace all solid
but let me just can I'd like to get into
a little bit about what the agencies
about how it works some of the issues
revolving around September 11th and and
and so forth I just give a brief
overview of what NSA is basically as
David said it's the largest intelligence
agency in the world and the most Secret
Intelligence Agency in the world the
show compare it to the CIA the CIA was
formed in 1947 by the National Security
Act it was a they had hearings there was
debate there was nothing secret about
the creation of the CIA the NSA however
was formed in 1952 by President Truman
and it was formed by a top-secret
memorandum and a contents that
memorandum has been secret for for many
years it was just a classified in the
last few years and that memorandum laid
out the the parameters of this very very
secret agency even the name was secret
its very existence was secret Congress
was not told about it they were
eventually about two people in Congress
that were told about it and that was it
eventually the name got out because of a
spy scandal and so forth but since that
time NSA has remained extremely secret
even today when you hear about all these
things happening with the intelligence
community you almost never read about
the NSA you read about CIA FBI all the
other agencies but NSA virtually never
appears in the in the press or very
rarely appears in the press I did
however do a piece for The Washington
Post last week
their outlet section along piece on
NSA's responsibility during the
September 11th attacks the agency
basically grew out of world war ii world
war two had the greatest successes in
breaking the german and japanese codes
and the german enigma machine and the
japanese propyl code and the US was in a
bad position when it was the war was
coming to an end we're about to go to
this cold war involving Russia the
problem was we had never Russia was our
ally during World War two so we'd never
paid virtually any attention to Russian
codes with one small exception known as
Venona but there was very little
attention paid to russian code breaking
so at the end of the war the US and
Britain decided they'd create this new
very secret organization known as tie
comm which even today is technically
secret the NSA still has the secrecy
wraps on tie comm for another five years
but I managed to get the documents
dealing with tie comm and what was it's
basically the US and Britain wanted to
get into Germany at the as the war was
coming to an end and captured German
code breakers and and code makers and
and a lot of their documents and
machines because they wanted to find out
two things he wanted to find out whether
the United States was vulnerable because
they if they had broken us codes and
number two they wanted to find out ways
that the Germans used to break Russian
codes so they went to Bletchley Park
where all the code breakers were outside
of London it's sort of like a monastery
and these were people that spent the
entire war sitting behind desks reading
these intercepts and a lot of them were
not in very good shape in the first
place they were former college
professors and so forth and then
somebody told him you're gonna have to
show up at 500 or whatever and get into
a plane and start parachute jumping and
they just couldn't believe it but they
were actually trying to train trainees
code breakers to drop into the front
line as a war was coming to an end and
use them to help capture these German
code breakers after the first two or
three jumps they
decided to give up that idea so they
transported all the codebreakers to the
frontline in trucks and it worked well
the u.s. found out that the Germans
never did break codes us Co is very very
much didn't do very well at it and they
also found that the Russians that the
Germans actually had done an enormous
job on breaking Russian codes and the
German Germans led the German prisoners
led the US and Britain to the location
where they billet buried this enormous
code-breaking machine and once the US
and Britain dug it up they were able to
immediately begin intercepting and
breaking Russian codes and it was an
enormous machine about I think was 40
tons something like that so the US was
able to go seamlessly from breaking
German Japanese coast of breaking the
German code and that will acid until
1948 when there was a spy in NSA's
predecessor and gave the secret away and
then Russia changed all its codes and at
NSA was long known as Black Friday at
that point during the 1950s NSA's poured
a lot of money into the computer
industry it basically primed the pump
for what is today America's enormous
computer industry because if you're
breaking codes the way to do it is to
get faster and more powerful computers
about this time the NSA came up with
another problem and that was during
World War Two there was censorship so
the Western Union and all these other
age all these other communications
companies had to turn over their
messages to the government code breakers
and intercept people but once the war
came to an end they ended censorship and
as a result NSA was without the raw data
for it's a interception and code
breaking to large degree so they began
working out a secret deal with Western
Union and these other companies and it
lasted for
almost well more than three decades
basically and this was a very secret
operation totally illegal
NSA worked out this agreement with
Western Union and the other companies
were Western Union would turn over every
telegram going through that company
during the entire day
at the end of the day they was turned
over to NSA and NSA would get copies of
them and this is totally without any
kind of a warrant normally if if FBI or
DEA or one of the other agencies wanted
to look at one message one telegram they
would have to get a warrant from an
impartial judge so this was called
Operation shamrock and the way it worked
out was the NSA built this phony
television tape processing company in
New York was actually in an office
building made to look like a television
tape processing company and NSA people
would go to the rear door of Western
Union these other companies after
midnight every night as per an agreement
the employee would through the backdoor
pass all that day's telegrams which were
on all these computer tapes to to the
NSA employee who would take him back to
NSA duplicate him in this place in New
York City and bring the originals back
before daybreak and then send the the
copies down to Fort Meade for analysis
so it was the largest probably the
largest of illegal eavesdropping
operation ever created in the United
States and it was a it was very
successful nobody found out about it
until 1975 when the Church Committee
discovered it and as a result of that it
came to an end and a lot of reforms were
created in the intelligence community
one of those reforms as a creation of a
very secret court known as a Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court even a
lot of lawyers I talked to have never
heard of the FISA Court but it's a very
interesting thing was created in around
1978 and since 1978 it has a unique
distinction of never ever having turned
the government down
and if the FISA Court does turn the
government down there is what's known as
a FISA appeals court which is sort of
and the judges that sit on it are sort
of the Maytag repairman of the judiciary
since since they were created in 1978
they have never once heard a case so so
that's one of the reforms that were
created after after the church committee
if the NSA now wants to eavesdrop on
what's known as the u.s. person it has
to get a warrant from this the secret
court but to be fair the Justice
Department has looks over these these
requests before they actually get to the
court and the Justice Department does
turn these requests down occasionally I
mean they they they have been known to
scrutinize these and the most
controversial case came with the the
recent case involving
Zacarias Moussaoui in in Minnesota
because the Justice Department turned
down the request for a FISA warrant and
never sent it to the the fysop port just
to stay a little bit more on on the how
NSA affected individual rights in terms
of eavesdropping NSA also had an
operation known as minaret where they
began Richard Nixon turned NSA inward
and began using NSA's advanced
technology to spy domestically on US
citizens primarily anti-war protesters
and when the agency was created I mean
it's just to give you an analogy here
when NSA was created it was created to
use against foreign enemies basically
people overseas and not domestically for
the same reason that we don't give
cruise missiles to local state police
departments I mean they may wanna would
like those but you know they're not
supposed to be used to mystically and
we're not supposed to use extremely
powerful and somewhat dangerous
intelligence agencies domestically
otherwise you're going to be creating a
Orwellian 1984 so that was why a lot of
these reforms were created and now
there's a
a movement to turn back a number of
these reforms one of the other things
that came up with just before I start
moving to the the more current current
day I found another thing that actually
had nothing to do with NSA so I just
don't want to tar an essay with this
operation but I did find it in the
course of research on NSA was a thing
called Project Northwoods and what
happened was during the 60s after the
failed Bay of Pigs attack that's where
the CIA was sent into Cuba to try to
instigate a rebellion and take over Cuba
else Fidel Castro it was a total failure
but after that failure the Joint Chiefs
of Staff the senior military people in
the country wanted to again they wanted
to go in and take over the country but
this time not to covertly they just
wanted to send the Army Navy and Air
Force in to have an overt invasion just
invade the country take it over I'll
store kill Castro and put in their own
leader so the problem with that scenario
however is that there was not going to
be very much support either within the
United States especially the OAS the
organization American states were within
our European allies for such an
aggressive action against a country with
that was not at the time doing anything
to United States wasn't attacking the
United States or anything so Operation
Northwoods was to create a justification
for this this war against Cuba and what
Operation Northwoods was was a roadmap
to create terrorism in the United States
the the actual document said people will
be shot on American streets bombs will
be blown up in New York and Miami
refugee boats from cue movies will be
sunk on the high seas all this to create
the impression that this is being done
by terrorists from Cuba and to lay out a
justification for attacking Cuba they
even had a plan that if John Glenn went
into
John Glenn was about to go into space on
his very first space mission actually
the very first space mission by the
United States and there was a plan in
operation Northwoods well if the rocket
accidentally blew up they would plant
evidence showing that showing that Cuba
did it
Cuba sabotage the rocket and killed
Glenn and destroy the US base program
they also have one other plan that
involved flying an unmanned plane that
was made to look like a charter plane
full of students over Cuba and then they
were broadcast it was a unmanned plane
flown by remote control but it would
have been a full-sized airliner and they
would broadcast a message saying that
we're being attacked by it was supposed
to fly in the vicinity of Cuba and the
message was gonna be we're being
attacked by a Cuban missiles or whatever
a few minutes later somebody at sea I
would have pushed a button and exploded
the plane over the ocean and Cuba would
have been blamed for destroying this
plane and killing these students yeah
they have one other one that was called
remember the main incident operation and
they were actually talking about blowing
up the u.s. Navy ship in Havana Harbor I
mean these were serious considerations
these were approved by every member of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff including the
chairman and then it got to Secretary of
Defense McNamara and he rejected it
at least there was one adult in the
Pentagon so all these things lead to
public skepticism about what government
does and I always found these documents
forty years after the case I mean forty
years after the event and they were only
turned out now because of a demand by a
group known as the assassination records
Review Board which had been set up by
Congress to take one final look into the
Kennedy assassination and they had an
enormous ability to force Congress to
enforce the government agency agencies
to release a lot of documents that's the
only way these documents got out
otherwise they'd still be secret which
leads me to say you know I kind of
wonder forty years from today what
documents were gonna be finding pulled
out of the archives or whatever so today
let me give you a little background and
tell you a little bit about NSA today
I'll give you sort of sort of a
thumbnail sketch of the agency and I'll
give you this yeah you know and
statistics that have give you a little
bit of an idea of the size and what it's
like the first of all it's located
halfway between Washington and Baltimore
and it's a on a military base known as
Fort George Meade
it's an enormous facility they it's so
big they the nickname for it is crypto
city and crypto city is it's a very
large area there's 50 buildings in there
including a chip manufacturing plant
it's surrounded by three fences
including an electrified middle fence
then there is anti anti truck bomb
boulders these huge boulders around it
than anti-tank devices and then they
have this group known as the men in
black which are people are dressed in
ninja black ninja outfits that come out
with losing machine guns is sort of a
last resort to defend the agency once
you're inside is a very unusual place
they have some of the officials have
very unusual titles one of them was
chief of anonymity
anonymity is one of the foremost ideas
concepts with an NSA if you pick up
their security book that's one of the
first things they talk about basically
it's keeping NSA's identity quiet so you
don't talk about the fact that you work
there you just don't don't talk about
NSA at all the newsletters which are
unclassified but and normally contain
very mundane things like what the menu
is for next week or whatever and the
cafeteria and they've got a phrase on
each one that says quote this newsletter
should be destroyed as soon as they have
been read or as soon as it has been read
so they take it very seriously there
this whole idea of security and again to
go back on the size NSA uses the same
amount of electricity that that the
state capitol does Annapolis the entire
city of Annapolis does one of the
interesting things and just a couple
other statistics they've got about
38,000 employees that work for NSA
inside crypto city there's 32 miles of
road it has 17,000 parking spaces
covering 325 acres there are 37,000 cars
registered in crypto city the post
office delivers about 70,000 pieces of
mail a day the police force has about
700 uniformed officer has its own police
force crypto city about 700 uniformed
officers which puts NSA's police force
in the top 4.8 percent of the nation's
police forces one of the things NSA
produces a great deal of is paper there
was a congressional investigation at one
point that not a congressional there was
a hearing at one point where NSA
employee testified and
he testified that NSA produces somewhere
between fifty and a hundred million
classified documents a year which is
more than all the rest of government
combined when all that is put on into
paper it's an enormous amount and the
way in us they handles it is you put it
in burn bags when you're finished that
these bags look like grocery bags and
staple them put them in these chutes on
the hallways and the chutes drop down to
conveyer belts all over the city and
they take these burn bags to a central
location it's to this big building known
as the pulp plant and they had this huge
bat in there and it looks like a huge
vat of oatmeal and that's the pulp and
they turn they convert all this paper
into pulp and last year they they sold a
lot of that pulp to this company for
fifty eight thousand dollars and the
company takes the pulp and turns it into
pizza boxes so next time you order a
Domino's Pizza if you take the pizza out
and hold the box up to a bright light
you just might see that what's left of a
of a message from a North Korean General
or something so the NSA is a mammoth
place with a lot of people in it that do
extraordinary work one of the things and
just to give you an idea the people to
some degree and as they tries to keep
the people very sociable they like to
keep the agency sort of like a family
more or less so there's clubs everywhere
in this all kinds of clubs and the idea
is to try to get a lot of NSA employees
to meet other NSA employees and marry
other NSA employees it cuts down on the
clearance problems if two NSA employees
me so you find an awful lot of NSA
employees who are married to spouses who
work for NSA and then their children
grow up and work for NSA so they have a
lot of clubs one of the things they also
have is and one of the clubs as a matter
of fact it shocks a lot of the people
who have retired a number of years ago
and when I tell them that it's this new
club a couple years ago called globe
which stands for gay or lesbian or
bisexual and pull
and so they actually advertise in the
globe advertisers in the NSA newsletter
and they hold their meetings and NSA
offices which is a enormous advance from
a few years ago when it would have been
certainly grounds for for firing the
employees not a firing squad for the
employee and they have they actually
have their own Film Festival there which
is one that you'd never see anywhere
else especially in Hollywood and last
year's Film Festival as a matter of fact
they had they have all these entries in
their native language they had one in
the native lap language they had one in
wolf which has spoken in Mauritania one
in Mora which has spoken in Burkina Faso
they had one in Mongolian and they
actually have like a sort of a
equivalent of like a blockbusters there
where employees can rent these movies
out in the 48 and 48 different languages
all in their native language so NSA has
the largest collection of supercomputers
in the world has the largest collection
of linguist at least in the United
States and in the the building that
houses the supercomputers is known as a
tour della supercomputer Center and it's
a place where time is measured in
femtoseconds 1 million billions of a
second and they're working on computers
now that will do one septillion
operations a second which which is one
with 24 zeros after it because in order
to break code you need super super fast
super powerful computers so anyway the
way NSA gets its raw material is by
intercepting it as it goes through the
air to a large degree has
listening-posts all around the world
these are places that look like moon
bases an average listening post such as
the one in those men with hill station
in england intercepts approximately are
an average of about
two million pieces of communications an
hour and that's faxes telephone calls
email data transfers whatever it just
pulls it all in like a vacuum and then
they use supercomputers to sift through
it and try to pick out the wheat from
the chaff they pull in so much
information and make such heavy use of
these computers at last February
February of 2000 all the computers that
NSA totally crashed it was one of the
worst days in NSA's history and they
they absolutely every computer in the
building crashed every computer in an
NSA crashed they actually had to go to
the British to have them help out
because the satellites are still picking
the information out but there was
nothing there to analyze the information
the satellite the computers were crashed
so they redirected a lot of it to
England and it took four days to get the
computers back online again so that's
one of the problems NSA has is just so
much information you wanna see if
there's anything else before I move on
to September 11th well it's just an idea
of how they do the interception a lot of
it's done by satellite for example you
put satellites in space and ground
stations on the on the ground you pick
up a lot of the satellite communications
satellite communications holds it is
what NSA focuses on largely and that
contains mostly are a lot of the
commercial communication so if you're
gonna call England or something the odds
are it's gonna go up to a satellite and
bounce down so NSA will have these
satellites out there collect all the
information and put it through the
computers another way is by collecting
microwaves if you see the little
microwave towers around the city and
around the country out in the out and
out in the country in the wooded parts
of the area you see the towers with the
little cones on them those are microwave
antennas and those are telephone calls
being sent by microwave signals from
tower to tower a microwave travels in a
straight line it always just travels in
a straight line
as opposed to high-frequency signals
which bounce off the ionosphere but a
microwave always travels in a straight
line which is advantageous if you're
eavesdropping because eventually that
line continued because the earth is
curved that line continues out into deep
space so for example from Moscow to
Vladivostok across Siberia there's a
whole line of microwave towers which
means that out in deep space there's all
these signals that are passing through
there are going from these towers and
they form like an arc so if you put a
satellite out there in geostationary
orbit over the equator and you focus on
that area you're actually eavesdropping
on those communications so that's sort
of in a nutshell how NSA does a lot of
the ease dropping
well I'll move on to September 11th
giving everything that I just said and
the size and the complexity and the
power and the number of personnel the
logical question is how how is it that
the NSA missed this September 11th and
it was an enormous intelligence failure
it's much worse than Pearl Harbor
because of Pearl Harbor the u.s. prior
to you know World War two when in prior
to Pearl Harbor the US had actually
broken the Japanese high-level code the
purple code they were reading the
Japanese intercepted communications and
we were intercepting their signals in
real time as they were sending him
between Tokyo and the embassy in
Washington so I actually picked up the
message to 13-part message that
basically indicated they were about to
go to war was a message that said at a
certain time tomorrow destroy all your
crypto equipment this is a message from
Tokyo to the embassy in Washington and
destroy all your codes and crypto
equipment to anybody that reads that you
know you understand something bad is
gonna happen pretty soon so they sent
out a message to a lot of places around
the world that something may
and it got to Pearl Harbor a little late
because they sent it by Western Union as
opposed to using high frequency because
the atmospheric conditions so yeah this
very sad situation of the this I wrote
about this in the puzzle files where
after the smoke started dying down the
employee in the western union office
took out the telegrams and went up to
Pacific Fleet headquarters and handed
the warning message to him so a little
late but the difference is in whirlwind
Pearl Harbor we had broken their
high-level code intercepted their
communications found out that they were
about to have an attacked some place and
actually sent out warning messages and
none of those things took place on
September 11th the none of the al-qaeda
didn't really used many codes but
whatever codes they use the NSA hadn't
broken
they weren't intercepting al-qaeda
communications in real time there was no
warning sent out and as a result the
attack took place at the time at nine
o'clock in the morning or you know
quarter to nine when the attack started
the director of Central Intelligence
George Tennant was in a restaurant
having a leisurely breakfast in downtown
Washington with an old friend of his so
you have this strange concept of you
know couch potatoes across the United
States lying on a couch or in bed
watching TV and learning about the
attack minutes before the secretary the
the director of Central Intelligence so
it was a total intelligence disaster NSA
probably probably the most embarrassed
of it all because NSA's like I said is
located halfway between Washington
Baltimore in this right outside this
little bedroom community NSA's bedroom
community of Laurel Maryland
well the terrorist cell that took over
the flight 77 that crashed into the the
Pentagon place they picked for there to
live and plan and do all their exercise
and and or can conduct their training
with Laurel Maryland
literally in the shadow of NSA and and
so you have this very strange irony of
on the morning of September 11th II the
terrorists got in their cars at the
Valencia Motel took a right turn on
route 1 heading south towards Delos
Airport at the same time they were
passing all the NSA employees in the
other lane going going north a few more
miles to NSA's parking lots so that
morning you had the actual terrorists
coming within two or three feet of the
people going to work to find the
terrorists so it was a real intelligence
disaster now the reason for this was
because the NSA was designed for one
purpose basically it was designed to
focus on the Soviet Union and warn give
early warning of a nuclear missile
attack and NSA did a very good job of
that during the Cold War I could tell
immediately if a plane took off from
some remote airbase and Russia NSA would
know about it or if a submarine pulled
out of a pen or if there was a they
decided on instead of the normal Tuesday
when they load up the the missile silos
with fuel they did it on a Thursday this
time there be an alert throughout NSA
because they would know about it well
the world changed when the Soviet Union
ended and NSA became the Soviet Union
became a third world country basically
as far as the intelligence community was
concerned and all of a sudden the
attention was paid on all these crisises
that were breaking out and NSA was not
prepared to handle all these crisises
because it was loaded with Russian
linguists who were no longer useful the
the listening posts were all basically
targeted to the Soviet Union everything
was geared to the Cold War and the
Soviet Union
so when US troops went into Haiti for
example NSA had a total of one Creole
linguist when we went into the Balkans
NSA had nobody that spoke Albanian and
very few people that spoke
serbo-croatian they had a screen
to find find people that would that
could speak it so you got a problem of
languages when September 11th happened
there were less than five people that
spoke Pashtun and dari the languages of
Afghanistan languages are a real major
problem and QWERTY according to one of
the senior or the senior person at NSA
dealing with linguist she said that NSA
said that the world has about 6,500
languages and there the number is
increasing because as ethnic nationalism
increases there's more of a move to
speak these of sort of dying dialects to
some degree out of the 6,500 NSA could
handle about 115 of those so languages
is a key problem the other another major
problem is the swamp of information out
there if you think back 15 years ago if
you're gonna send a piece of written
communications that would be in a letter
or in a document form that would be
sealed in an envelope and sent through
the mail
well that doesn't happen anymore people
use the email they use the internet they
use worldwide web they communicate
electronically so all that information
that was once kept from NSA because of
envelopes and postal systems is now
available to NSA or anybody that has the
technical capability to intercept
signals going through the air so NSA has
all this additional information that's
out there to go through in addition
there are all the cell phones that are
out there that weren't out there 15
years ago so you've got this and and you
know just the influx of computers and so
forth so we've got this enormous amount
of information out there that needs to
be gone through of NSA's gonna find this
electronic needle in a haystack so those
are two of the problems languages and
the influx of communications finally the
I'll just say a little bit about how
this incident took place and why why
they miss the specific incident what NSA
was geared up to do basically is watch
for indicators of terrorist indicate
terrorist incidents those indicators
were normally trained large well they're
basically about three of them one is the
the movement around the world of known
terrorists who are on watch lists and so
forth another thing is the movement of
large amounts of money to various
suspicious people and the third thing is
the transfer of large amounts of
explosives in September 11 none of those
things took place basically the people
that came into the United States came in
legally they lived here legally all but
two of them only two of that that group
about 20 were well only two of that
group were on any kind of a watchlist
all the rest came in without being any
kind under any kind of suspicion and
finally you've got the problem of the
way they were communicating they
communicated in the form of cells so
they would just talk face-to-face with
each other basically they did
communicate occasionally by using the
internet but they would go to internet
cafes and libraries use anonymous
computers and and and servers and
communicate using very innocuous
messages you know the equivalent of
remember uncle Harry's birthdays next
week and the packages do arrive on
Monday or whatever which you know if
you're doing word spotting you're not
able to find and you're not able to
target those computers anyway because
you don't know they're using them and
you don't not able to target them
because you don't know they even exist
so and then finally there was the
problem of always looking outward when
these people were actually living in
word in the United States so all those
problems contributed to NSA's failure
and those are some of the things that
you know we're probably gonna be on the
agenda to to correct
I worry a lot about these new procedures
coming out of Washington these new
policies especially creation in this new
office of homeland defense which
according to the the government that are
according to government officials will
be the second largest government agency
in the entire country second only to the
Pentagon this is one enormous agency and
I also wonder it's one of the functions
is supposed to be analysis of
intelligence and
you know I thought that was what the CIA
was supposed to be doing but in addition
to that the this is supposed to be
analyzing all the the intelligence from
all the different agencies to look for
terrorism
but that's why they set up the Center
for the National Center for
counterterrorism at CIA to be an all
source analysis from all the different
agencies so I mean there's a lot of
questions that have to be asked about
all this
this new reorganization and what what
what its gonna do how much duplication
and one of the key questions is how much
is it going to eavesdrop or how much of
this intelligence is going to begin
focusing on US citizens there's a big
problem of tearing down the firewall it
was built up in the 1970s to separate
the intelligence agencies from the
American public so it doesn't go back to
creating the oppressive situation that
existed in the 60s and 70s that had a
that led to a lot of illegal spying on
US citizens so all these questions have
to be asked the President's speech was
only 11 minutes and certainly didn't
answer many of those questions and those
are the questions I hope the press will
be asking in the next few days anyway I
appreciate your attention and I'll be
happy to take whatever questions you you
have yes sir oh okay and thank you sir
everybody goes to a microphone okay I'll
wait for the microphone
here comes the microphone right here the
closest question about Operation
Northwoods two things one it was
apparently originally put together in
the waning days of the Eisenhower
administration was it not it may have
been I'd have to go back and look at the
exact dates of the documents I actually
what was put together in the waning days
of the Eisenhower administration was
actually the Bay of Pigs operation which
was a total failure Northwoods came
after after the failed Bay of Pigs there
may have been some elements that
pre-existed or predated the kennedy
administration most of it took place
during the the months following the Bay
of Pigs which was 1961 Kennedy ever
approve Northwoods
number one and what was the general
impression of the NSA and our
intelligence agencies at toward Kennedy
what was it what was their relationship
with him yeah good question see as far
as I know and most the documents have
been destroyed the deal with this entire
period neither John Kennedy nor Robert
Kennedy although there's more of a
chance that Robert Kennedy might have
known because he was in charge of this
operation Mongoose which was sabotage
within Cuba but as far as I know it got
as far as as McNamara and had McNamara
approved it he probably would have taken
to the president or to Robert Kennedy
for approval but since McNamara turned
it down as far as I know it never went
any higher than McNamara and the
question was what was the attitude of
NSA towards towards you no NSA had
always been a very it still is too large
to be a political organization
and there are exceptions during this
turn during its history its 50-year
history but mostly it's run by a general
or an admiral who comes in for three
years leaves and then replaced by
another general or Admiral the Deputy
Director who actually runs day-to-day
operations as a career cryptologist who
rises up through the ranks and has
almost no political connections
whatsoever so NSA is a very a political
organization and didn't really play much
of a role in terms of political
atmosphere in the Kennedy administration
so I don't know whether they liked him
or didn't like him there I don't think
there was much of a feeling about him
within the Joint Chiefs of Staff well
within that within the CIA was run by
Allen Dulles at the time and he was more
or less a Eisenhower protege a large
degree and I think there was some
mistrust by the CIA of Kennedy there was
a great deal of mistrust of Kennedy by
the Joint Chiefs of Staff the people who
created Operation Northwoods
I found documents were they actually the
chairman Liman Lannister sent messages
by courier to his generals and in Europe
saying critical things of the Kennedy
administration sending him so that they
wouldn't be transmitted electronically
so NSA would pick them up and the
Kennedy administration would read them
but I actually found some of these
documents now it was very it was a very
dangerous time I just finished this
little with this little anecdote if you
remember the book and later movie that
came out called seven days in May about
a military takeover of of Washington
that didn't come out of the thin blue
out of the blue air blue sky there was
that atmosphere around Washington at the
time I did research on it for body of
secrets and it's very interesting how
how the military disliked Kennedy and
didn't trust him and there was this
atmosphere of fear to some degree of a
military takeover which led Fletcher
Annabel to right there
right the book next question first
question second question if they were a
military takeover today do we know what
it would look like it's interesting
questions yeah the the the the first one
is very easy the second one is not the
NSA the director of NSA which is a
three-star Air Force general Michael V
Hayden reports to the Secretary of
Defense like most of the intelligence
agencies what most people don't realize
is the Director of Central Intelligence
only controls 15 percent of the
intelligence community the person who
really runs the intelligence community
is the Secretary of Defense he controls
the other 85% he controls NSA he
controls the Defense Intelligence Agency
controls the National Reconnaissance
Office controls national imagery and
mapping agency controls all military
intelligence bureaus and so forth and it
goes on and on so the structure of
central intelligence controls the 5,000
man clandestine service of the CIA
that's about it well thirty billion
dollars a year is basically the budget
well it didn't work for the reason I
explained as far as NSA goes it didn't
work for the CIA for another reason
because of lack of a imagination to a
large degree and and this is a complex
of thinking about the last war all the
time thinking about the Cold War so you
have this weird situation on CIA people
graduating from the farm that's their
training school then Williamsburg
Virginia to be clandestine officers
within the CIA and the the tradition in
the Cold War was they get sent to an
embassy someplace imposes a cultural
attache or whatever and they go to
cocktail parties and they try to recruit
members of the host government to steal
secrets former or become spies for them
and largely that's what continued during
the post Cold War period and the problem
is you're not going to find many
al-qaeda members at a cocktail party in
breda Vienna Austria they should have
done what John Walker Lindh did which
was grow a beard study the Koran went
around the Middle East for a few years
of establishment bona fides and then
walk into Afghanistan and you know it
turns out they welcomed John Walker
Lindh and they welcomed a number of
Brits and German Germans French
Australians and over other people from
Western countries so that was the
failure I think of the CIA
I mean if John Walker Lindh they're all
these other people that were in there
but there wasn't one CIA officer that
ever got in and that's their job is to
sort of infiltrate these organizations
so the CIA claimed for years was
impossible because these are clan based
organizations they have family ties they
know each other well if it's impossible
then you know how did these other people
get in so I think that's something that
the CIA's gonna have to you know have an
interesting answer for during these
hearings and the second question had to
do with what if there was a military
coup in the United States what would it
look like yeah I'd have to actually sit
down and think about that for a while
cuz I've never really thought about it
off the top of my head I wouldn't have
any idea the military I mean they've got
far more restrictions on them now than
they did back in the back in the early
60s but it it's an interesting question
I can't really give an answer off the
top of my head because it would be
wouldn't be accurate and I'd really like
to think about it but it's a good
question to think about thank you
next question back there
disarmament issues with the UN and there
a lot of human rights experts are
talking about these new weapons that
target the mind and they're warning
about the I was wondering if you and
your research ran across any of the
so-called mind-control weapons or heard
rumors about it
and her rumors about her number of
things for years the intelligence
community been involved with various
aspects of psychic phenomenon and so
forth remote viewing and so as CIA
actually had a whole did a whole study
on remote viewing where you know you're
go like this you could read some memo in
a in a Moscow vault or something like
that I don't know how useful it is I
have a very big skeptic on that but I
don't know very much about that topic
NSA one of the NSA's responsibilities
however is cyber warfare and they're
very they've been spending a lot of time
and money developing capabilities to
alter alter the world and particularly
enemies by altering the communications
infrastructure within the country in
other words like going to war with
melosa vision former Yugoslavia and
using cyber warfare to destroy the
communications infrastructure empty his
bank account turn off all the
electricity power plants around the
country and so forth NSA is involved in
that is called information operations
but in terms of actual mind control I I
really don't know sorry
when you wrote the puzzle pals 20 years
ago must have certain conceptions about
the NSA now 20 years later and you had
some insight you know view or tour what
things now give me the maybe the two top
misconceptions you had 20 years ago
that's been corrected from this dis
additional research yeah there's all
good questions here um one of the things
that I always had a misconception of and
I think most people do when you when you
find an NSA employee and you start
talking to that employee I'm
generalizing now but it's sort of a
accurate generalization
you know you think these people work at
the actual forefront of Technology they
are involved in intercepting looking for
bin Laden a lot of times the first thing
you thought about is how far they have
to park from the building yeah hey you
know and that makes you think again this
is a bureaucracy like any other
bureaucracy these people work there for
20 years the thrill of the actual
initial doing the work to some degree
has passed and it's become a job it's an
average everyday job and I found that
back then I found that today also that
the the the employees are very average
when you talk to them they're like every
other government employee they're good
workers and they they're they're very
patriotic and honest and all that and
they they have mundane concerns like
everybody else but so that was one of
the big surprise I thought you know
they'd they be talking about this latest
computer they just developed or whatever
and it's you first start with the
mundane issues like are they gonna
increase the the cost-of-living
allowance or something like that so the
other well this the other surprising
thing from the last book to this one I
think was again the the enormous change
from focused during the puzzle palace
everything was focused on the Soviet
Union and we're gonna get enough Russian
linguists in here and and built more
listening posts around the Soviet Union
today it's a completely the opposite
it's how are we gonna find enough
Lingala and
Mangala spoken in the Congo or enough
Karen linguist which has spoken
along the Burmese Thai border and so
forth and and the other major problem is
are we going deaf that's another major
issue at NSA right now are we going deaf
because the technology would choose to
be NSA's friend has now become as enemy
telecommunications companies are
switching from satellites to fiber-optic
satellites you just put a big dish out
there and it's like catching rain
collecting these signals fiber optics
are light signals that go through glass
fibers in a cable in a very cable that's
much more difficult for NSA to tap I
mean they can tap into them they can
intercept that but they have to access
the cable which is very difficult and
it's a normally more difficult problem
so the question is with all the data out
there the the new use of fiber optics
and so forth is Denys they going deaf
and that would never would have been a
question twenty years ago lack of
knowledge by our representatives who's
there
during these congressional hearings to
ask the right questions well yeah yeah
another good question the the problem
you have with congressional oversight is
the basically the the problem is that in
numbers NSA for example 38,000 employs
approximately that's just NSA it's not
counting CIA dia when I
every other alphabet soup agency out
there
the total member of this number of the
staff and members of the of the Senate
and House Intelligence Committee
community are about our Senate in-house
intelligence committees are about maybe
200 or something I mean give or take a
hundred or whatever and the Senators in
congressman this is only one committee
among many they serve on and the
employees to a large degree are former
employees of the agencies are looking
into I mean not all but a number of them
are so you get a problem of this small
little group with can they adequately
look at an agency that's enormous ly
gigantic and that has so many
classifications I mean there's some
documents that you look at in tough
secret it's just the starting point in
NSA most documents its top-secret umbra
with about five other code words after
it I mean these were well above top
secret so and all those
compartmentalized information so you
have a small group of people responsible
for these enormous agencies with
unlimited amount of secrecy and and the
other factor that I think is important
is that when the these intelligence
committees in Congress were formed in
1975 they were formed for largely the
sole purpose of protecting the American
public from these big intelligence
agencies it's our only line of defense
basically and given what went before I
showed that we needed that line of
defense but now after all these years
the the atmosphere or the culture or the
the attitude has changed and it's not so
much protecting the American public from
these agencies it's the attitude of the
congressional committees is put more
money to these agencies build these
agencies up bigger make them able to spy
better which you know depending on your
point of view that's probably an
important aspect but if your point of
view is that you want to be protected
from the
the agencies that's not really in the
forefront of the of the Intelligence
Committee time anymore and you know into
in just in their defense the agencies
haven't reverted to those tactics they
used back then at least at least I was
about to say at least as far as I know
having you know done two books on NSA
and interviewed a lot of people I
haven't found anybody doing these
illegal things but again I'm an outsider
looking in so that's why I do like
intelligence committees to have a very
big responsibility to to work to find
whether the agencies are obeying the law
or not yes next question well there's a
whole range of occupations most of the
people that go to work for NSA these
days or have technical backgrounds they
they employ the largest number of
mathematicians on earth and because
mathematicians are what you need to
break codes a lot of times they employ a
lot of computer scientists electrical
engineers and linguists and then a
number of liberal wise people who do
work in the non operational side of NSA
or else in the area of studies that kind
of thing so a lot of when they leave NSA
they go to work for computer companies a
lot of the people actually go to work
for the defense contractors there during
the Eisenhower administration there was
all this worried about the crypto or
rather the the military-industrial
complex and today I mean there's this
enormous crypto and industrial complex
that involves NSA and these defense
contractors I mean not saying it in a
pejorative way but it is a very big
activity and now there's now something
that there really is to worry about to
some degree is this new thing security
industrial complex we have all these
companies
they're building security devices new
ways to bug people new ways to spy on
people and they they're out there trying
to sell them to the office of homeland
defense or the intelligence community
whatever and the problem is they once
they're built they're also out there
selling them to private industry which
don't have as many restrictions on them
as government so yeah there was a piece
on it was CBS Evening News a few weeks
ago that this guy invented this this
thing is sort of what's known in the
community is magic lantern type of
technology where yeah you it's a
software program that that immediately
transmits the actual keystrokes a person
is typing on their computer so you can
actually in a remote location secretly
watch what a person is typing and by
doing that you're they could have the
best encryption system in the world but
the actual keys are always going to be
the right keys that you're pressing
we've hit hello you know you're always
gonna press the H and the other letters
to form that that letter so that's very
dangerous so if somebody a thousand
miles away is sitting there watching on
their computer as you're typing
everything and you know so if you go
back track and and and erase something
you've already the person's already seen
it so it's really the one of the most
intrusive things we've ever heard of and
you know the person sold it to the US
government which is using it but then
they're commercially selling it to the
to the public too so that's one of the
things I worry about is this security
industrial complex that's developing now
with this you know huge semi hysterical
rush on on anti-terrorism a couple of
times you've mentioned years ago 75 76
77 there was another way of getting
information from submarines and
underwater cables and I wonder if you
have information is that still happening
that yeah so that was known as operation
known as IV bells and it was one of the
most spectacular of all NSA's operations
in terms of the audacity of it basically
in the success
and what it was was the Russians
wouldn't use some of the most sensitive
information would not go by microwave or
by satellite or it would be encrypted
when they used it but they were sending
enormous amounts of information by
undersea cable especially the cable that
went from the Russian Far East under the
Civic whisk to Kamchatka Peninsula so
the NSA developed this idea of getting a
submarine and they would sail up our
periscope skull blanks along this
coastline of the sea of Kursk and what
they were looking for was this this
assign because whenever you have a cable
going under the sea there's usually a
sign on the beach to warn fishermen and
people not to drag their nets in that
area so they did that and so they're
going secretly along the coast and they
saw that sign and then that's where they
have especially built submarine with
skids on the bottom so it would just sit
on the bottom and they went down sat
very near the cable and I actually
interviewed the person who was the NSA
person on the submarine in charge of the
entire operation this wasn't through
permission of NSA it was develop my own
way but so it was very interesting they
they they had the divers on the
submarine that were capping this capsule
on the on the sub for about two weeks to
acclimate them to certain atmospheres
and gases and so forth and then when it
was on the bottom they were released
from this little capsule and they swam
to this repeater which is this sort of
device between where the cable gets
amplified basically and it turns the
cable into an electrical pulse and
that's one of the things that they look
for so the divers came out of the
submarine they went to the side of the
submarine open this little sliding door
and pulled out this these two long
cables they look like jumper cables
basically pulled him out and they attach
them to the to the repeater and
immediately they began listening to the
tapping the Russian communications and
they spent about a month down there
tape-recording all these conversations
and then they at the end they've sailed
back to the to the airport i think they
went back to guam flew all the tapes
back to NSA and it was very successful
eventually they developed this bug that
was actually buried under the silt on
the floor bed and the cable would just
sort of rest on top and through
induction they were picking up all the
signals so if the cable had to be
repaired the the Russians could pull it
up and there'd be nothing on it and they
could even send a diver down there
unless the diver pushed away the salt he
wouldn't see the bug but the the
operation came to an end because this
guy Ronald Pelton who was a former NSA
employee needed money and he sold that
secret to the Russians for I don't know
how much but which led to a really worse
situation because he sold a secret
around 1981 the US didn't discover that
he sold the secret until around 1985 so
between 1981 and 1985 the Russians knew
everything that was going over that
cable so there was a large potential of
sending disinformation over that for
about four years yes two more questions
we began reading Orwell five decades ago
we're left with sort of a presumed
opposition's on the part of the state
and I'm wondering if the lesson of
September 11th might be that given the
complexity of information and
bureaucratic sluggishness of
governmental organizations that
political systems might simply be
incapable of dealing with a complex
world well I think I think it's true to
some degree the although you have sort
of the reverse situation here in
September 11th you have a complex
organization not being able to deal with
a simplistic organization I mean you're
dealing with you taking this enormous a
complex agency known as the National
Security Agency with computers that
they're working on to do the septillion
operations a second and more
mathematicians than any place else on
earth and what they were trying to
and what the other side had was a group
of individuals with weapons that they
bought in True Value Hardware some box
cutters and some plastic knives or
whatever and a plane tickets plane
tickets they bought over the Internet
all the rest was you know a clever plan
but in in terms of technological
organization it was the ultimate and
simplicity so you had the ultimate in
complexity being defeated by the
ultimate and simplicity in this case one
of the analogies in Orwell's world 1984
however which I see parallels today is
that in in 1984 there was always a war
going on they were either fighting East
Asia or you were Asia but it was always
a war because Wars what got people
together behind the government and it
really made no difference whether it was
East Asia or Eurasia the point was the
war all the time so I sort of see that
in this war on terrorism a bit you know
it's just you got to have this thing
going constantly and you don't look at
those the origins of it which is the
Middle East George Bush came in
apparently not even knowing where the
Middle East was or if he did he
certainly it never entered his radar
screen that maybe there may be a problem
there some time until the whole thing
explodes and if they don't start paying
attention to resolving the enormous
crisis in the Middle East then you know
you can just it's like a wave all the
always happening there is just gonna
come this way like a tidal wave yes
another question thank you very much
this subject about the military being
involved and George Bush's father's on
the board of the seventh largest
military defense contractor I some of
you probably know that the Carlyle Group
and also connecting the dots which is
what I've been trying to do died
corporation I don't know
and a man named herb Winokur who was on
the board of Enron is also the head of
dying corporation and he's also on the
board of the Harvard Development
Corporation and it's just interesting to
watch who these players are and how
they're interconnected and you know a
lot of it is involved with the military
yeah I think you really gonna I focus on
NSA so I'm not familiar with all the
intricacies of the connections there but
I think you really do have to focus on
it if this was Bill Clinton in office
the Republicans would be finding all
kinds of scandals involving a Carlyle
Group just like whitewater or whatever I
mean there'd be digging up every single
scandal there was if Bill Clinton
knocked over a ashtray they'd have a
congressional investigation so they're
not out there doing it and the president
seemed to be doing too much probing into
any of the backgrounds of some of the
people in their connections with the
with this again the security industrial
complex and so forth so I agree it's a
it's an area that needs to be probed
more closely you know as long as you
want
I don't know if you saw the announcement
for your talk but at the end it says mr.
Bamford will explain why he believes the
NSA is dangerous and what all Americans
should know to protect themselves would
you like to address that yeah I didn't
know that was gonna be in it
NSA does have NSA does have a history of
illegally eavesdropping on US citizens I
wrote all about it in the puzzle palace
and wrote more about it here I mean that
is dangerous so when you have that
agency that can do that I don't think
NSA is a bad organization I think NSA is
a good organization I think it does good
things I think it's got to be watched
and I think has got to be careful you
know I'm I'm I'm not an anti NSA person
I'm not for doubling its budget
necessarily it's there's somewhere in
between there where I think NSA can do
useful visit there juice full things
during World War two deduce real things
during during the Cold War and it might
be able to do useful things during this
so-called war on terrorism I'm a you
know I'm a skeptic I want to see what
happens and how it works and I'm also
worried as I've mentioned numerous times
tonight about the dangers of using this
technology to letting it get out of
control and I think that's the danger
with NSA the people I've interviewed
there as I mentioned before I think are
very honorable and honest and do a good
job and do what they're supposed to do
and they're not out there trying to
illegally eavesdrop on people the
problem comes when you have an
administration in the White House that
directs them to do that they're not
gonna go out there and think oh why
don't we go eavesdrop on everybody in
Cincinnati today or something it's not
the way it works it's the president
comes out and says I think protesters
the anti-war protesters are being funded
by foreign organizations and therefore
there are national security threat and
therefore we should begin eavesdropping
on anti-war protesters dr. Benjamin
Spock and so forth that's what happened
during the Nixon administration that's
what worries me
what you have here is the perfect storm
you've got the administration where you
have an enormous amount of secrecy
coming in all of a sudden enormous
secrecy over everything you've got an
enormous new agency being built up
that's being gonna be second only to the
Pentagon and largely what its going to
deal with his domestic intelligence and
at the same time you've got the tearing
down of the reforms that came during the
1970s oh that's a very dangerous
dangerous time is NSA itself dangerous
it could be dangerous if if a president
decides to use it in a dangerous method
that's the way it was done during the
Nixon administration so per se in Prior
September 11th I would say no wasn't it
wasn't a very big danger because the
people there don't seem to be interested
in in creating a 1984 situation post
September 11th who knows you know that's
why I want you know more people like you
more journalists more people in Congress
to take a closer look at this agency and
you know keep it keep it honest
basically so anyway thanks very much for
your attention
James Bamford worked as an investigative
reporter for ABC News and has written
two books on the National Security
Agency his most recent is body of
secrets anatomy of the ultra-secret
National Security Agency it's published
by anchor books online at anchor books
calm